نعم فدا ارتفع عدد الشهداء نتيجه الغاره
الاسرائيليه التي استهدفت منزلا ماهونا
بالسكان ودون سابق انذار وفي ساعات الليل
في مخيم خانيونس الى سبعه من الشهداء
بينهم طفلان وسيده بالاضافه الى اكثر من
20 جريحا وصلوا هنا الى مجمع ناصر الطبي
عدد من الجرحى بحسب الاطباء هنا جروحهم
خطيره وهذا من المتوقع ان يرتفع عدد
الشهداء نتيجه هذه الا باات الخطيره التي
وصلت من بين الجرحى الذين وصلوا الى مجمع
ناصر الطبي ايضا الطائرات الحربيه
الاسرائيليه لازالت على حالها تحلق في
اجواء مدينه خان يونس بالاضافه الى طائرات
الاستطلاع الاسرائيلي التي تحلق على
ارتفاعات منخفضه سمعنا دوي انفجارات ناجمه
عن قصف مدفع اسرائيلي استهدف مناطق متفرقه
من المدينه بالتزامن مع تواصل اطلاقات
ناريه من الاليات العسكريه الاسرائيليه
وايضا اشتباكات تدور في اكثر من محور
تحديدا في المح المحور الجنوبي الشرقي
وايضا المحور الشرقي من مدينه خان يونس في
مدينه رفح سبق الغاره هذه الغاره وهذه
التطورات في خانون السابقه غاره اخرى
استهدفت ارضا زراعيه تؤوي نازحين ادت الى
ارتقاء خمسه من الشهداء بينهم اربعه من
الاطفال طفل من هؤلاء الاطفال اربعه هو
طفل رضيع لم يتجاوز العام من عمره
بالاضافه الى التطورات في وسط القطاع
والقصف المدفعي الذي لا يتوقف على مخيمي
البريج والمغازي وايضا الاطراف الشماليه
من مخيم النصيرات ما ادى الى وقوع عدد من
الاصابات بالاضافه الى الاضرار الماديه
الكبيره التي لحقت بالممتلكات وبمنا ازل
المواطنين نتيجه القصف المدفعي الذي يتركز
في منطقه وسط قطاع غزه هذه الليله